[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm munich und
das war in einer 3 von büchern
namensgebers und deswegen musste ich
gleich im vorwort erklären ob er great
war und ob er mit ivo war ja gesagt der
leser darf für sich selbst entscheiden
wie grey terra aber ob er mit ivo war
ist schwer zu sagen weil mein neunter
jahrhundert wenn es ein johannes gibt
was mit ivo ist was mit deutlich ist
dann merkt dass leute wahrscheinlich
also ich glaub kern des mittelalters ist
war ich eigentlich für uns gleich acht
das zwölfte oder dreizehnter
jahrhunderts 1400 werde es schon
vielleicht kontrovers 15 jahrhundert
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
mittelalterlich aber mein problem war
eher dass das wort mittelalterlich
eigentlich also sowieso irgendwie
komisch mittel halte
da könnte man sich vorstellen zwei
mittelalterliche leute sitzen zusammen
sang man ich kann nicht warten bis
mittelalter vorbei ist sie freuen sich
schon auf die renaissance
es ist also offensichtlich eine
sozusagen eine externe definition
zwischen antike und renaissance und man
sieht schon
ich hab auch in der in der parkallee
aber ich auch bemerkt mittelalterliche
philosophie dass die einzige fluss wie
die mit einer beleidigung beschrieben
wird
mein bitten dich ist irgendwie schlecht
damit natürlich ist alles dunkel
als rückwärts gegangen und so weiter und
vor allem in der mitte zwischen die 22
phasen der menschlichen geschichte und
der französischen geschichte die wir
immer loben und groß machen nämlich eben
antiken oder etwas das vorweg ist das
problem
die islamische welt noch schwieriger
denn natürlich haben es hatten sie auch
keinen kein begriff mittelalter auch
später eigentlich nichts also es wird
sich eine europäische beschreibung und
man könnte fast sagen mittelalterliche
philosophie in der islamischen welt ist
einfach für das wir in der islamischen
welt in der zeit während mittelalter in
europa stattgefunden hat ländern ist
natürlich bekanntlich war das ein
höhepunkt für philosophie und für
wissenschaft und kultur im allgemeinen
in der islamischen welt
die größten denker der logische
geschichte in der islamischen welt
lebten alle im mittelalter bzw
die denker die wir als bildungs und groß
kennen es gab wie dann später sagen
werde
also es gibt sozusagen eine legende dass
philosophie in der islamischen welt mehr
oder weniger im zwölften jahrhundert auf
herz schlägt das ergebnis in spanien der
letzte islamische denker ist und das ist
völlig falsch wie geht einfach weiter in
der islamischen welt gesundheit noch mal
mit begeisterung dass das mag ich also
wenn schon denn schon in philosophie und
genießen
sogleich jeden fall die es gibt es gibt
hunderte philosophen nach dem zwölften
jahrhundert in der islamischen welt und
das habe ich alles in der podcast serie
abgedeckt was sie dafür interessieren
aber das ist eigentlich egal denn wie
ich jetzt erklären werde in dieser
vorlesung unser thema betrifft die
islamische welt fast überhaupt nichts
weil es einfach keine philosophen den
muslimischen philosophinnen oder
christliche oder jüdische philosophin in
der islamischen welt gibt's in unserer
zeit also in der zeit die wir als mit
deutlich beschreiben was bleibt vom 8
vielleicht von entstehung des islams bis
13 uhr händler jahrhundert man könnte
weitergehen und mindestens die hypothese
machen dass es keine weibliche
philosophinnen in der islamischen welt
gibt das vielleicht neunzehnte
jahrhundert und dann hauptsächlich im 20
jahrhundert
es ist ganz deprimierende geschichte die
ich entdeckt habe als ich eine folge
einer barkasse schreiben heute über
frauen im islam und ich wollte dann zu
sagen die frauen identifizieren die man
als philosophin beschreiben könnte und
dann erklären wer sie waren was sie
gesagt haben also mehr oder weniger die
ich in dieser vorlesung mache und was
ich herausgefunden habe ist dass es
anscheinend nichts zu sagen gibt
wir haben sogar an mehreren
forscherinnen geschrieben die waren alle
weiblich die die experten sind für
frauen im islam
ihr habt gefragt der welt gingen ein als
philosophin es muss nämlich philosophin
und die haben mir alle namen erwähnt aus
dem 19 oder 20 jahre als jahrhundert
niemanden davor
also wir können sagen hier haben wir
wirklich ein hinsicht in wem christliche
europa ich werde immer latein
christentum sagen ich hab sogar nach
gestellt ob das ob das ein deutsches
wort ist latein christentum als norman
und google erkennt das als ein
existierendes wort also also ich habe
18.000 dafür bekommen also ich weiß
nicht ob es die denken dass latein
christentum existiert als wort aber ich
und google schon also sie verstehen was
ich damit meine ich nicht ein
christentum man könnte europa sagen aber
es ist auch schwierig weil die
islamische welt dass das für eine lange
zeit spanien und portugal ab also europa
ist schwierig ich habe vielleicht
irgendwann schon gesagt dass der
ausdruck westliche philosophie oder
abendländische philosophie
das gefällt mir auch nicht weil spanien
portugal ziemlich weit im westen sind
wie ich immer sage terrorist hat weiter
westlich gewohnt als thomas von aquin in
spanien also diese teil dieser erste
gestern schwierig deswegen sage ich
immer latein christentum für mindestens
für die phase die uns interessiert ok
also das heißt es gibt drei praktisch
gebiete wie die zu betrachten sind als
mittelalterlich und was ich hier unter
wie gesagt und damit letztlich verstehe
ist wirklich mehr oder minder achte bis
zehnte fenster jahrhundert ja ich werde
vierzehnter jahrhundert wie es sich als
ziemlich betonen müssen weil mehrere mit
als übeltäter so finden im vierzehnten
jahrhundert gelebt haben
also für mich hört mittelalter mehr oder
weniger in 1400 und wobei wir werden
auch christin fdp sahen betrachten das
ist die letzte figuren die wir
besprechen werden sie lebte bis ins
konzert ihr 100 also ist das ist die die
zeit lang war sehr interessiert und
geografisch gesehen betrachten wir
natürlich latein christentum also
christliche europa im mittelalter aber
auch griechischsprachige europa und
kleinasien sprechgesang klinische reich
und islamische reich wo der islamische
bleibt und an was ich heute erklären
wenn ist warum ich dann die restliche
zeit nur nur über latein christentum
sprechen werde
es gibt schon frauen und denkerinnen die
man erwähnen kann aus besonders und aus
der arabischen welt aber es ist bei
weitem nicht so interessant wie im
latein christentum das ist an sich
interessant und lässt uns also ich finde
es schon überlegenswert wie so könnte
das sein in meinem latein christentum
ist eigentlich dafür bekannt dass sie
weit hinten der islamischen welt waren
in dieser zeit und das stimmt in den
meisten als päckchen waren sich schon
weniger entwickelt als die islamische
welt war sozial wirtschaftlich und so
weiter man kann auch die dateien
christliche welt mit der griechische
jeweils vergleichen
und da würde die la times ist wird auch
nicht unbedingt so gut ausschauen
mit diesem vergleich also es interessant
zu bemerken dass trotz dieser so
schwierigen lage in der time christentum
in dieser zeit trotzdem
haben wir mehr frauen die für die werke
oder vielleicht französische werke
geschrieben haben die noch erhalten sind
als aus der islamischen welt
oder eben aus der griechischen welt dass
das sage ich bin und das werde ich jetzt
belegen nun begründen diese beobachten
allerdings muss ich im voraus sagen dass
das sage ich mit einer gewissen mit
einem gewissen vorsicht weil ich nicht
ausschließen kann dass es irgendwelche
philosophinnen gibt die mir unbekannt
sind
ich kann nur sagen ich habe geschaut und
fast nichts gefunden
und das wenige was ich gefunden habe
werde ich jetzt entfalten für sie so
schnell daran wovon wir reden also wie
viel also wie liefen dass sie sich in
dieser zeit entwickelt hat
wir haben römisches reich dynamisches
reich ist groß in der grössten zeit von
großbritannien nicht ganz gänzlich aber
hauptsächlich großbritannien schottland
selbst nicht und schottland bleibt für
jetzt großbritannien und in der eu aber
wer weiß also wenn leute die aufnahme
dieser vorlesung in fünf jahre schauen
zu sein
aber ja damals schottland teil der
egal also großbritannien im westen des
syrien im osten
und was passiert kurzum westliche reich
entfällt und das für uns sagt sozusagen
mittelalter zu haben
karl der große und die karolingische
zeit aber ausser dieser zeit haben wir
eine lange periode nach dem nach dem
deutlichen reich in latein christentum
wo die lage für philosophie wirklich
sehr sehr schwierig ist
ich würde sagen die die zeiten die ich
habe wieder
natürlich schauen müssen wegen der polka
serie was gibt es zusagen für
lateinische philosophie zum beispiel mit
zwischen mythos und pathos aber dass in
solchen jahrhunderts es gibt schon was
zu sagen wie zum beispiel yoga johannes
gottes erhöhen
im 19 jahrhundert eben an der an hof von
den kalorien kaisern ihn gibt es gibt
zum beispiel anzeigen muss es gibt eine
reihe von philosophen in der früheren
zeit die ich nächste woche werde gibt es
auch ein paar frauen die werke in dieser
zeit geschrieben haben
aber der erste dunkle zeit also die dort
ages wie man auf englisch sagt das ist
nicht unbedingt falsch für die zeit
zwischen sagen wir von sitten des elften
jahrzehnten jahrhundert zum beispiel
senken jahrhundert es gibt nicht nur
keine philosophinnen es gibt was keine
philosophen in europa im zehnten
jahrhundert also das kann man das kann
man wirklich zu sagen auf einer hand
sein und diese figuren sind nicht sehr
interessant könnte man sagen
das ist dann anders ab dem elften und
vor allem ab dem zwölften jahrhunderts
also im zwölften jahrhundert kommt also
zu sagen wirklich in gang wieder
es gibt wieder so eine legende oder weit
verbreitete meinung übermittelte die
philosophie das mittelalterliche
philosophie praktisch tot ist oder nicht
sehr interessant ist bis sie alles dort
ließ wiederentdecken und deshalb habe
ich auch irgendwie immer gedacht bevor
ich das meer recherchiert habe und jetzt
würde ich sagen das ist eigentlich
falsch
es ist nach dem grund einen großen und
größten unterschied denn das nordries
wieder auftaucht bei zuerst haben sie
nur ein paar logische werke für alles
dort ließ und dann im späten 12
und dann füllen 13 jahrhundert
übersetzen sie fast alles was alles
geschrieben hat oder was alles was wir
von alles lesen können natürlich sind
viele viele werke werke von einer story
ist sowieso verloren habe die wir sind
fast alles was zu übersetzen also zuerst
gab und das hat riesige einfluss auf dem
dreizehnten vierzehnten jahrhundert das
stimmt aber davor gab es schon sehr
interessante für solche entwicklungen im
zwölften jahrhundert auf basis der
übersetzungen die sie schon hatten auf
basis augustinus und so weiter also man
kann nichts sagen dass wir sozusagen nur
die ages bis wie das wiederentdecken
das alles haben und dann und dann erste
medaille für das vieh vielmehr haben wir
mehr folgendes bild nicht sehr viel nach
zerfall des römischen reiches sehr
interessant in der kardiologischen zeit
war mit der jugend dann nicht sehr viel
im neunzehnten jahrhundert dann fängt
alles wieder an zu wachsen im 11
und wird sehr interessant im zwölften
jahrhundert aber dass zum beispiel im
zwölften jahrhundert
es gibt viele debatten viele solche
debatten über universal ihn und andere
philosophische probleme ethik und erst
danach nach dieser blieb im zwölften
jahrhundert kommt alles lotterie ist
wieder rein und dann haben wir albertis
magen dass thomas von aquin des chores
und so weiter und so fort
okay das ist latein christentum diese
geschichte ist ihnen wahrscheinlich alle
bekannt dann gibt es bis ans bis 1
technische reich ist ein irgendwie ein
irre führende ausdruck indem man davon
den eindruck gewinnen könnte das was
neues mit also bislang cent steht
irgendwann bis ein teenager ist nur
russische reich wo er noch existiert
also es ist nur die östliche hälfte des
römischen reichs vor lang bevor diese
aufsplittung und uns der fall dass wir
mit des westlichen likes hatten sich
sowieso
ihr hauptsitz in konstantinopel und
nichts in rom mehr und das ist sehr
wichtig weil diese stadt so gut
verteidigt weil hatte so große mauer das
zitat fast unbesiegbar waren was sie
können im zweifelsfall hinter diesen
aussitzen bis der feind werk geht und
das hat haben sie gerade gemacht also
sie haben gerade geschafft was zu machen
als die muss nicht mehr gekommen sind
die haben versucht konstantinopel zu
erobern und haben und das sind daran
gescheitert
also das heißt ist an technische
philosophie ist eigentlich nur mehr und
mehr spätantike philosophie könnte man
sagen und das empfehlen weisen erstens
wir viel mehr als im westen haben wir
wirklich kontinuität kulturell gesehen
also wir haben nur leute die sich römer
nennen und die die nannten sich römer
die haben sie auch würmer also die
griechen die das anti mische griechen
heißen arabisch
sie sind die leute des raums obwohl sich
natürlich nicht in rom wohnen und die
nahmen sich auch römer also erstens
zweitens ein paar sprachlich gesehen das
ist immer noch auf altgriechisch nicht
zu sagen das griechisch sich nicht
verändert mit der zeit natürlich tut tut
sie das
dass sie das schon aber die sprache ist
mehr oder weniger gut erhalten und das
ist für uns sehr wichtig heute war wie
ich wahrscheinlich schon irgendwann
erwähnt habe die griechische werke die
wir noch lesen können sind die
griechische werke die in business
erhalten waren und immer wieder kopiert
würden von schreiber die immer noch
altgriechisch nicht nur konnten sondern
auch sprachen also das ist also ich
würde sagen bis ein teenager philosophie
ist nur die das überleben der antiken
philosophie sprachlich politisch könnte
man sagen weil es immer noch römische
reich ist und drittens wichtigsten dann
wechselten von dem stoff her ist bei
bisschen technische bloß wie sehr
bekannt wenn man mit spätantike kommt
denn sie schreiben kommentare auf das
dort ließ die lesen platon die treiben
neuplatz muss und so weiter ist es
wirklich sehr sehr ununterbrochen könnte
man sagen
allerdings gibt es natürlich in der
byzantinischen crosby und sogar schon
ins später in der spätantike mehrere
entwicklungen innerhalb christlicher
theologie und je nach dem wie
wie offen man ist christliche theologie
christliche theologische debatten als
philosophische betrachten kann man
schlagen es gibt wirklich
charakteristische kantine schiffe sowie
die entwicklungen innerhalb dieser
debatten und wie sie wissen bin ich sehr
offen und was alles als also ich bin ja
fast alles offen solange es mir
philosophisch interessant scheint und
deswegen würde ich das als teil der
geschichte plötzlich auch betrachten
aber da ist das biz angst und also und
hier wäre es wert wäre es gut wenn ich
eine landkarte zeigen könnte aber nur
grob
wir haben latein christentum bis ans und
islam als islamische welt ist riesig
groß im vergleich sogar zum damaligen
römischen reich weil die das ist nicht
nur vom besten in europa hier spanien
nicht gerade bescheiden aber spanien
nicht nur von da bis syrien sondern von
da bis indien
das ist die islamische welt also man
könnte sagen also wenn außerirdische die
welt senden jahrhundert anschauen würden
würden sie denken okay es gibt ein paar
christen hierüber aber die mehrheit der
menschen sind entweder muslime indisch
oder chinesisch also das sind die die
haupt zivilisationen in dieser zeit
nichts christlich ist die situation und
das zeigt sich in der geschichte
philosophie zum beispiel neuen t zehnte
elfte jahrhundert das ist ein höhepunkt
von philosophie in der islamischen welt
gleichzeitig mit der niedrig mit dem
lied eckpunkten kürzlich in europa also
in dieser zeit haben wir alle kennen die
alv arabi hat mit seiner harley und und
und und und übrigens auch christliche
und jüdische philosophin zum beispiel
jacken hat die mühlen der kritiker
meinen dies sei die agan und andere
jüdische philosophie
alle männer also das ist sozusagen die
panorama wo wir jetzt sind im
mittelalter und unser der frage ist dann
deswegen nicht nur welche philosophie
nennen gab es in latein christentum in
dieser zeit sondern welches
philosophinnen also wenn ihr
mittelalterliches groß denken welche
philosophinnen gab es in christlichen
europa ist nicht europa griechisch
römische reich und islamische welt
natürlich könnte man auch fragen was ist
mit indien china japan und
wahrscheinlich könnte man mich vorwerfen
dass es das ist nicht gerechtfertigt ist
dass ich jetzt über die islamische welt
spreche aber nichts mehr über indien
erzähle wie ich schon vor zwei wochen
gemacht habe und ich erzähle ich
überhaupt nichts über japan oder china
das liegt nicht daran dass ich eine gut
einen guten grund dafür habe das lied
rhein an meine grenzen einen jetzige
wissens grenzen
es kann sein dass ich in 15 jahren
nachdem ich das alles abgedeckt habe mit
dem podcast es ganz sein dass ich sagen
würde ich kann nicht glauben dass adams
sind in 2010 das und das und das alles
gelassen hat als er diese freunde diese
vorlesung gegeben hat also ich sage ich
es an meinen zukünftigen selbst tut mir
leid
wir suchen jetzt ich würde es so viel
also denkerinnen das weibliche
philosophinnen in diesen drei kulturen
wenn es welche gibt
andererseits erinnerung diese vorlesung
geht nicht nur darum philosophinnen zu
finden sondern auch mindestens ab und zu
zu besprechen was ansichten über frauen
in dieser zeit bauen was war ein
philosophischer ansichten über frauen in
dieser zeit also man könnte sich fragen
gibt es texte die von männern
geschrieben würden wo sie frauen
besprechen genau wie platon und
aristoteles das gemacht haben und sagen
sie was interessantes über frauen in
dieser zeit und hier wäre meine antwort
wahrscheinlich nie mehr oder weniger
nein
also es gibt so weit wie ich weiß keine
werke mittelalterliche werke aus dieser
drei kulturen die frauen besprechen und
so intensiv und so interessant vor allem
wie die politiker des platons wird
deswegen gibt es zum beispiel keine
vorlesung über frauen bei thomas von
aquin zum beispiel nicht dass man das
nicht machen könnte natürlich sagen
viele philosophen in dieser zeit
irgendwas am passat über frauen zum
beispiel warum frauen nicht so gut sind
die männer oder warum es überhaupt
frauen gibt es ein sehr liegt ein
lieblingsthema ist ob geschlechts nach
der letzten auferstehung und geschlecht
erhalten wird also werden sie alle
verstehen als frauen und männer oder
werden sie alle als geschlecht lose lose
wesen wieder zurückkommen dass diese
frage ist schon zum beispiel in der
spätantike bei augustinus zu finden wird
von jugene besprochen und so weiter
normale antwort ist ja
wir erhalten unser geschlecht aber nein
wir werden kein sexualverkehr
was macht man mit sexuell verkehrt
machen durchsehen genießen
hoffentlich genießen genießen das werden
wir nicht mehr machen weil es ähnlich
wie essen also wir machen das aus
irgendwelchen körperlichen mangeln
und deswegen werden wir das in paradies
nicht machen also sagen gute und
schlechte nachricht
aber es interessant dass frauen zum
beispiel nichts dadurch belohnt sind
dass sie gut waren dadurch dass sie
männer werden
das ist nicht der fall erfreulich das
ist auf jeden fall das ist vielleicht
ein zeichen dass vielleicht im gegensatz
zu dem was wir in den indischen
tradition gesehen haben mit der
inkarnation usw scheint es in der
christlichen tradition so sein dass
geschlechts gehört wirklich zu der
entweder individuell individualität
also ich als peter hanson bin unter
anderem peter thompson weil ich mein ich
bin das gehört zu sagen meine
persönlichkeit und wird für mich immer
erhalten seien auch später nachdem ich
auferstehen
ok also es gibt diese theologische
fragen aber und dann gibt es vielleicht
eine andere sehr reiche quelle für den
über frauen im mittelalter und nämlich
literatur zum beispiel gerade vorgestern
in meiner podcast serie ist eine folge
erschienen über roman della rossa also
wo man es der rose und das ist ein dass
es ein gedicht über das versuch eines
mannes eine rose zu packen und das ist
ein symbol für sex und dann der und die
der mann der das machen modell ist der
dichter selbst und dann gibt es viele
andere gestalten um ihnen die
verschiedene aspekte einer liebesaffäre
verkörpern es zum beispiel neid oder
freund oder schlechter ruf oder was auch
immer
oder liebe also gott der liebe
und es gibt dann viele reden von all
diesen verkörperungen sind bayerische
verkörperungen vernunft auch auf und
natur taucht auf und die geben ihm alle
beratung wie er diese frau bzw
rose dann gewinnen könnte und das sind
mehrere reden über er über frauen und so
weiter drin wie philosophisch das ist es
natürlich eine andere frage
ich würde sagen die teile dieses textes
die frauen besprechen sie nichts
besonderes philosophisch es gibt für das
sowie die teile des textes aber wir sind
nicht die teil die frauen besprechen ist
oft sehr sehr frauenfeindlich
dieser text übrigens wirklich wohl
frauenfeindlich sehr empfehlenswert es
wirklich macht das ist wirklich spaßig
und lustig aber sehr feindlich also das
wäre ein beispiel vielleicht ein anderes
beispiel wäre dante und die göttliche
komödie
nicht zu vergessen wer ihnen durch
paradies für pc ist eine große liebe die
und das ist anscheinend angeblich eine
echte frau indem er sozusagen von ferne
verliebt war
also hat sie gesehen ist praktisch in
rund macht gefallen weil es weiß ist
hübsch ist und dann erst setzt sie
wirbel und stay sich als führer wenn er
dann paradies erreicht weil er kann
durch paar paradies nur von einer
christlichen person geführt werden und
die christliche person die aus gewährt
wird das zu tun ist bärtschi also sie
verkörpert sozusagen meine weiblichkeit
mit vernunft und verständnis dass es
wirklich sehr interessant zu betrachten
warum dante eine weibliche person
gewählt hat für diese rolle
diese zwei beispiele die gegeben habe wo
man daraus und die göttlichen gemälde
sind ein zeichen für ein phänomen was
uns den tipp oft beschäftigen wird in
den kommenden wochen nämlich dass wir
oft ideen über frauen und werke von
frauen nichts in lateinischen texten
finden sondern in fuchs sprachigen
texten also vom handel der größe
natürlich auf französisch
die glückliche dir bekannt welches auf
mittlerweile italienisch die relative
ähnliches zu jetzige italienisch zum
teil gegen dante und mehrere von den
frauen die ich in den kommenden wochen
besprechen werde gesundheit haben nicht
auf lateinisch geschrieben sondern auf
deutsch oder was auch immer französisch
und fast könnte man vielleicht sagen
dass die dass frauen im mittelalter in
einer in einem blog sprachigen kontext
verortet sind und dass sie
wahrscheinlich vorkommen ihn werke die
irgendwas mit philosophie zu tun haben
dass zum beispiel vom handel der holz
und die göttliche komödie
die sind wahrscheinlicher in texten
vorhanden die nicht auf lateinischer
geschieden wurden das ist interessant
und das werden wir besprechen müssen
warum das der fall ist
noch interessanter ist die frage warum
hatten frauen die gelegenheit texte zu
schreiben aber normalerweise nicht auf
lateinisch und das werde ich werde was
in dieser vorlesung darüber sagen
ok also das sind 22 arten von text wo
man suchen kann
aber meiner meinung nach ist ein
wichtige quelle für ideen über frauen im
mittelalter und eine quelle die
sozusagen philosophie nah ist gesetz
also gesetzliche werke und das in allen
drei kulturen deswegen wollte ich das
ein bisschen thematisieren
gleich am anfang warum ersten zwei drei
kulturen wirklich sehr von gesetz
geprägt sind
das ist offensichtlich in islam wo wir
jüdische und muslimische kultur haben
und jüdische und muslimische religion
werden oft als gesetzt passiert
beschrieben und so recht sie es gesetz
wirklich sehr sehr bestimmend für die
ganze installation
das ist nicht ganz so der fall in der in
der christlichen religion natürlich kam
jesus um die alte kiste zu entfernen
oder zu erneuern oder wir haben wenn man
das beschreiben möchte aber trotzdem war
gesetz auch ein sehr wichtiger faktor in
christlichen europa und bis 1 also ich
fange damit an und sei kurz passt dazu
die wichtigste quelle für gesetz in
christen der klassischen welt und bis
ans so wohl wie im dateien christentum
ist die gesetz sammlung des kaisers
justinian und das kommt aus der mitte
des sechsten jahrhunderts also wissen
sozusagen an der kante zwischen
spätantike und mittelalter also würde in
528 initiiert das heißt er hat sozusagen
befehl gegeben die gesetze zu sammeln
was war das als text das ist nicht ein
versuch all die gesetze neu zu schreiben
vielmehr war das ein versuch die
disparate
und schwierige texten des römischen
gesetzes zu zusammenzubringen und
vernünftig zu strukturieren und das
haben sie dann geschafft das existierte
auf griechisch und latein
und natürlich war der sehr maßgebend für
gesetz in byzanz aber auch im westen
also wenn man schwarz ins 513
jahrhundert texte über juristische texte
basieren sich hauptsächlich auf
justinian auch im westen und das geht
dann in mehr oder weniger in zwei
richtungen
weil justinian und seine sein team die
das halt geschrieben haben
sie waren der ansicht dass der kaiser
nicht nur ein säkularer führer ist
sondern hat irgendeine rolle in religion
es ist sowieso ein kopf der kirche nicht
nur kopf der nicht religiösen
gesellschaft
das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade
ein bisschen anders aus mit dem papst im
westen habe grob könnte man sagen dass
gesetzlich gesehen der papst die rolle
des kaisers im besonders ersetzt und man
findet parallele zum beispiel dazwischen
die sie die mächte des papstes
beschreiben und wie sie die märkte des
kreises beschreiben
und wie gesagt es geht deswegen den zwei
richtungen es gibt sozusagen allgemeinen
gesetzt gesetz und es gibt bully
religiöse gesetz reagiert religiöse
gesetz ist zum beispiel wie die kirche
ist strukturiert werden soll
aber das gibt es in biologische und
sogar philosophische fragen
hier ist ein sehr wichtiger text ein
werk von petsos lombardo was so
maßgebend war für die theologie
geschichte in latein christentum dass
jeder dialog am anfang seiner karriere
diesen test kommentieren müsste also es
gibt natürlich viel über diese text ist
zu sagen aber ich drücke wollte das nur
erwähnen weil frauen relativ oft in
diesen texten vorkommen als thema sie
nicht als ob sie sagen okay jetzt buch
sieben frauen
vielmehr kommen sie immer in anderen
kontext im haus in politisch als
politische frage als theologische frage
also nur ein paar zu erwähnen
sie besprechen warum es ist dass jesus
männlich war
sprich man könnte sich fragen warum
hätte sein können dass also wenn gott
sich verkörpern will als mensch könnte
er sich könnte er sich als frau
verkörpern
antwort nein aber frauen müssten
mitgeteilt sein damit zu sagen die ganze
menschheit irgendwie eine irgendwie mit
damit verbunden ist und deswegen war es
passend nicht vergessen er hat jesus hat
keinen männlichen vater er hat aber eine
männliche nutzer also die idee ist gott
der vater und maria die mutter haben
beide eine rolle
diesen männlichen sohn zu produzieren
und deswegen gibt es
eine männliche also ein männlicher
mensch nun ein weiblicher mensch als die
spin beide eine rolle in der ein fleisch
um gottes andere frage oder andere art
von frage ist politisch zum beispiel
hatten sie das problem manchmal dass
frauen politische macht erworben haben
zum beispiel weil sie die königin
überlebt wenn der könig stirbt oder weil
die das älteste kennt weiblich ist
beginn des königs darf so ein kennt
regieren obwohl es sie weiblich ist
oder ein anderes beispiel was oft sind
zur personen römischen antike
vorgekommen ist ist der kaiser ist nur
fünf jahre alt wer regiert für ihn
manchmal irgendwelche leute mal die
mutter und in der in der römischen
geschichte in der antike und auch im
business gab es fälle wo der faktische
kaiser eigentlich die mutter des
kreisels wollen und deswegen haben sie
in diesen gesetzlichen kontexten sich
gefragt ob das wirklich okay ist also ob
frauen regieren dürfen und die
argumentieren in beide richtungen
eine andere interessante frage oder art
von frage hat mit e ist zu tun zum
beispiel berg an wen heiraten aber auch
was ist zum beispiel mit einer frau
nachdem ihr mann stirbt kann sie zum
beispiel besitz der familie behalten
oder muss ein mann gegen 1
irgend ein männlicher verwandter dann
reinkommen und das haus übernehmen oder
die übernehmen
das ist natürlich nicht unverwandt mit
der politische frage weil man kann
politisch im markt als familienbesitz
betrachten also dieses 2 sachen kommen
irgendwie zusammen
hier ist eine interessante beobachtung
dass in der latein christentum angeblich
die eine ehe nur gültig ist wenn die
frau freiwillig zustimmt zu heiraten
also kein zwangsheirat das ist
ausgeschlossen
in latein christentum also das ist nur
beispielweise ein paar beispiele was man
aus diesen texten gewinnen kann um zu
verstehen wie mit alte leute frauen
gesehen haben
nicht weniger relevanz natürlich über
und eigentlich noch für relevante
wahlgesetz in islam und judentum und
hier möchte ich euch ein kleines
bisschen über wie gesetz in bislang
funktioniert sie werden sehen warum das
relevant ist okay so wir wollen
islamische gesetzt haben und hier werden
wir nicht einfach sagen okay wir sind
die römer oder die nachfolge der römer
also wir werden römische gesetz
übernehmen sondern will man eine
islamische juristisch entwickeln wie
sollen wir das machen
antwort wir haben zwei quellen für
islamische gesetz erstens natürlich der
koran das heilige buch die offenbarung
die mohammed gebracht hat aber auch was
sich hatte nannte hat heißt so etwas wie
geschehen ereignis also die sachen die
in mohammeds leben passiert sind
und das ist selbst auf eine passage oder
mehrere passagen im koran passiert wo
wir lesen dass muslime mohammed in alles
in allem folgen
das nachahmen sollen zum beispiel gibt
es sogar beschreibungen in den handys
wie er seine fingernägel geschnitten hat
oder was das erste war das was er
gegessen hat nach nach also in hama dann
woher die ganzen den eigentlich gegessen
hat was das erste was man hessen soll
danach antwort datteln weil man habe
immer im daten angefangen hat und
deswegen würde sehr wichtig bericht
nicht nur den koran zu können sondern
auch berichte über die taten und wörter
mohammeds zu informieren und diese zwei
quellen sind die zwei kann die voraus
islamische gesetz gebaut würde
man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen dass
dies irgendwie wichtiger ist als quelle
aus dem körper natürlich nichts von der
qualität her aber von der masse her also
es gibt tausende tausende berichte über
mohammed und was er sagte und was er tat
und die müssen und gute muslime sollen
so sahen sich anpassen auf seine wörter
und taten und die würden immer daneben
als basis für juristische entscheidungen
genommen natürlich in dieser sitzung
also man könnt ihr übrigens sagen das
ist vielleicht ein versuch den koran zu
bereichen der koran ist relativ lang
aber nicht so lange und es gibt viele
fragen die man sich dann könnte wo man
einfach kein keine antwort in dem koran
finden kann und deswegen wenn man auch
all diese berichte aus dem hut die aus
der antiken literatur auch hat hat man
eine 43
cd auswahl oder viel mehr informationen
die islamische gesellschaft
funktionieren kann ja hat dies sollte es
kommen also jetzt haben sie das gehört
nicht unbedingt
ich glaube das ist das ist etwas wo also
wenn man cursor über das lan macht oder
so das hört man sehr schnell ist es
wirklich sehr wichtig aber die ist schon
nicht so gut diese idee könnte fragen
wie viele leute tradition gehört hatten
aber auf jeden fall wichtig zu wissen ja
und natürlich kann man sich ob man
könnte sie fragen okay wenn wir unsere
ganze gesellschaft nach diesen berichten
dann allein schirm sollen
es werde eigentlich wichtig zu wissen
welche berichte war sind und welche
falsch weil die männer so ein bericht
ist mehr oder weniger eine anekdote die
jemand erzählt genau wie also sie haben
ein lieblings brockel und in der familie
wird immer gesagt onkel toni hat mal
gesagt immer die hände waschen vor
fleisch essen aber wenn sie nur gemüse
essen dann nichts und haben viel respekt
für onkel toni und und dann sagt tante
hortensia nein er hat umgekehrt gesagt
ich hätte vielleicht ein besseres
beispiel als denken
aber sie verstehen was ich meine und
hier würde es oft politisch sehr heikel
ob die berichten war waren oder nicht
zum beispiel gab es als fertiges zweite
über theologische fragen wie zum
beispiel der temp determinismus oder es
gab hat dies mohammed sich dazu geäußert
hat uns der termin ist ish klingt und
dann andere wo er anti die termin ist es
klingt und es naheliegend dass
irgendjemand diese hat es erfunden hat
um ihre seite ist zu stärken und das
würden muslimische gelehrten sehr früher
sehr klar und deswegen haben sie ein zu
sagen eine wissenschaft entwickelt oder
einen mindestens eine methode entwickelt
die berichtenden superzahlen bis wie
stark oder schwach schäfer sie waren und
ein starker aktiv war ein aktiv die eine
starke kette hatte es naht das heißt ich
habe es von ihnen gehört sie haben das
von ihr gehört sie haben es von ihr
gehört
und sie war dabei als mohamed das gesagt
hat und das ist deswegen klappt würde
gewalt sie glaubwürdiges sie und sie und
ich sowieso
also das heißt jede jedes aktiv kommt
mit einem mit einer kette dieses nahm
jemand hatte also ich habe es von
jemandem gehört und er hat von jemandem
gehört er als von jemandem gehört
vielleicht sieben schritte zu demjenigen
der da war als mohamed das gesagt hat er
getan hat also die so sind die der regel
zeigt die originelle zeuge noch besser
ist wenn man das mehrfach belegen kann
durch mehreren ketten die über mehrere
leute und die müssen alle glaubwürdig
sein
warum ist das alles wichtig weil frauen
eine sehr große rolle in dieser in
diesem verfahren gespielt haben
erstens war es vor allem in den früheren
generationen war es ja üblich dass die
leute die die hat dies vermittelt haben
die waren oft frauen und eine von dem
wichtigsten quellen
eine von den christen fällen in der
ersten generation also sagen die erste
zeuge worauf mehrere ketten zu erkennen
war seine war mohammed lieblingsfrau
aisha und sie hat hunderte hat dies dann
vermittelt und wenn man hat die
literatur nicht wer kommt man immer
wieder auf falsche also sagen erste
glied der kette und deswegen könnte man
sagen dass sie eine sehr große rolle
hatte in der gestaltung des islams so
wie wir das kennen und die andere frauen
mohammed spielten auch eine rolle aber
bei weitem die heftigste hier
und weil die jetzt genau wie an
muslimische männer mohammed nach amazon
sollen muslimische frauen
die frage die ehefrauen mohammeds
nachahmen kormoran mit auch relevanz
aber sozusagen als voraus und man die
ehefrauen von mohamed maach an
und weil sie so mitgeteilt von in dieser
ganzen in diesem ganzen verfahren haben
frauen oft dann die rolle gespielt wo
sie die sozusagen die nächste generation
über die hat erzählt haben
wir finden auch auf den seiten finden
wir oft dass muslimische gelehrte die
die hat es weit gebracht waren von der
mutter oder von einer er gern eine
andere anderen verwandten weibliche
verwandte und das ist das ist wirklich
wichtig und interessant
natürlich kann man mit behaupten dass
das alles philosophie ist aber es ist
ein zeichen dass frauen doch eine rolle
spielen konnten innerhalb einer
wichtigen intellektuellen in einem
wichtigen projekt zusagen des islams
allerdings was man schon über beobachten
kann ist dass frauen eigentlich sehr
wichtige rolle in den ersten
generationen spielen und dann nach einer
weile nicht mehr mit beteiligt sind und
das ist deswegen dass es krank ist kann
dazu dass es gab so viele handys und es
war so schwierig geworden zu sagen was
war war und wir also was stark waren was
nicht und deswegen haben die forscher
versucht hat die sammlungen zu schreiben
wo sie alle hat dies bewertet haben also
sehr stark relativ stark sehr schwach
sehr schwachen wie auch immer und die
haben dann das dann eben mit diesen
köpfen gemacht und um das zu tun müssten
sie weit reisen viele leute interviewen
so viele zeugen finden wie möglich also
nicht direkte zeugen weil es zu spät war
aber zeugen die sagen könnte ja ihr habt
von ihm gehört
und das war für frauen nicht möglich
also es war ein eine aufgabe für
unabhängige männer die alleine reisen
konnten und diese gelehrten die das
gemacht haben und die erste sammlung
geschrieben haben
die waren alle männer es ist es scheint
dass frauen sozusagen sehr wichtig sind
früh in dieser ketten dann sind diese
erste große hatif forscher männer aber
nachdem sie den korpus der hat die fda
gestellt haben bekommen frauen wieder
rein also nachdem sie sagen zum sohn
frisch schon verstehen was stark ist und
über schwach übermitteln oder vermitteln
frauen diese hat die oft innerhalb der
familie ist interessant ok also dass das
basis das müssen die müssen gesetzes
übrigens in judentum kann man das gar
nicht sagen
also gesetz im judentum ist natürlich
super super wichtig war um ähnlicher
weise näher als eine quelle und nicht
nur tolle oder bettwäsche bibel im
allgemeinen sondern gibt es aus der
spätantike diese zwei texte die mission
das ist eine sammlung der angeblich
mündlichen überlieferten tradition aus
der zeit großes durch die viele
generationen von rabbis und dann gibt es
die talmud oder die zwei talmud das sind
kommentare auf die mischna wo sie
erklären was was diese mündliche
tradition bedeuten soll
und jemand wie zum beispiel meine
monarchis ein jüdischer gelehrter für
das war nicht richtig
rolle für ihn war es jüdische richter
und genau wie ein muslimischer richter
entscheidungen treffen müssen auf basis
der islamischen gesetzen so genau so im
judentum
aber so weit wie ich herausfinden konnte
war diese ganze ist ganzes spiel mit
jüdischen gesetz war wirklich was für
männer
also sofort nichts oder vorwiegend
nichts was wo frauen mitgeteilt worden
in ein bisschen im gegensatz zu der
situation mit islamischen gesetz also
ich werde eigentlich nichts mehr darüber
sagen okay jetzt können wollen sie sich
würden sie vielleicht fragen was all
diese gesetze über frauen tatsächlich
sagen
und hier kommen wir so eine frage die
relativen kontrovers ist nämlich die
stellung islams frauen gegenüber
und natürlich wieder könnte man ein
ganzes semester lang darüber sprechen
und das werde ich nicht tun als auch
nicht mein main gebiet aber nur ein paar
beobachten
der koran und islamische gesetze sind
eigentlich dafür bekannt dass sie sehr
frauenfeindlich sind zum beispiel dass
man mehr als eine frau heiraten kann
aber eine frau kann ich mehr als einen
mann heiraten oder wie frauen sich
anziehen dürfen wie sie sich benehmen
dürfen haben so weiter allerdings jetzt
gibt es gute gründe zu denken dass die
ursprüngliche koranische offenbarung
unter anderem ein versuch war die
situation für frauen in an dem ort und
in der zeit zu liberalisieren oder
mindestens zu argumentieren und klar zu
sein
ein gutes beispiel dafür ist eben diese
regelung für frauen ist erlaubt der
punkt ist leute jungs nur für frauen ab
jetzt nicht acht nicht nur vier
beschränkt ihr beschränkt ihr also
beherrscht euch mehr oder weniger wurden
ist sehr wichtig nur mehr als eine frau
wenn du in der lage bist alle gleich zu
behandeln und alles finanziell zu
unterstützen
also du darfst nicht eine frau
politisieren ausnahme übrigens firma hat
mohamed er dürfte mehr als wir frauen
haben
er hatte eine besondere offenbarung
gekommen dass das e mail abfall als
prophet aber andere männer dürfen neu
vier frauen haben und nur unter dieser
bedingung
es gibt es gibt gelehrten des islams in
des 20 jahrhunderts zum beispiel machen
dazu die argumentiert haben dass der
punkt dieser passage aus dem koran ist
das dass man nur eine frau haben darf
weil der punkt werde so was wie man
dürften nur mehr mehr als eine frau nur
haben wenn man in der lage war sie alle
fälle gleich zu behandeln aber natürlich
ist das nun möglich deswegen daten
jemand das machen also ein bisschen und
überzeugend aber trotzdem ich habe das
ist gute gründe gibt zu denken dass dass
diese zum beispiel dieser diese
bestimmte regelung war sozusagen ein
versuch frauen zu beschützen
und das gilt für andere regeln die wir
im koran finden oder islamischen gesetz
im allgemeinen zum beispiel scheint es
dass eigentums und
für frauen viel besserer und den islam
als vorher
also die haben praktisch gesetzt dass
frauen zum beispiel von den eltern erben
dürften oder dass sie bis zu dem was ich
vorher gesagt habe dass sie haushalt bis
jetzt behalten dürften in ihrem eigenen
namen nachdem der ehemann stirbt
ähnlicher weise als ein präparierter
maßnahme die wir die wir ins land finden
ist geht um scheidung und zum beispiel
das einmal nur dreimal sagen muss ich
scheide dich mit die scheine mit von
hier ich hatte mich von dir und dann
sind sie geschieden
aber nochmal könnte man sagen im
vergleich zu den vorherigen regeln die
in der zeit geherrscht haben weil die
legalisierung oder die die
reglementierung des schadens eine
verbesserung für frauen gegenüber was
vorher existiert hat es gibt auch
übrigens eine stelle im koran wo die die
scheint sehr zu sagen frauen sehr gleich
mit männern zu bauen also alles was gut
ist für eine frau ist gut für ein mann
es gibt allgemein kann man vielleicht
sogar sagen dass im christentum und im
islam man mindestens die idee hat dass
jeder mensch frau oder mann dadurch
erfolgreich wird je nachdem was die
beziehung zu gott ist und dass frauen
diese richtige beziehung haben können
genauso wie männer das bild auch eine
rolle wenn man so was kommt ich war
gleich sagen werde ein interessantes
eine interessante denken die ich hier
erwähnen möchte und das mache ich zum
teil weil das interessante ist als eine
auslegung des islamischen gesetzes und
ich wollte auch mindestens eine
muslimische denkerin erwähnen
und das ist eine frau namens fatih man
many say sie es mit nichts mit seitlich
sie ist sehr sehr nicht mit leidlich es
gerade gestorben ich glaube in 2014 und
die war soziologie professorin in
indonesien und hat mehrere bücher auf
französisch geschrieben über die
bedeutung des islams und ich die lage
und stellung der frauen innerhalb ist
lang und was sie argumentiert ist
wirklich sehr interessant
also ist sie ist sie argumentiert mehr
oder weniger in dem gleichen sind wie
ich gerade gemacht habe nämlich dass die
ursprüngliche offenbar ein versuch war
frauen zu helfen aber dann argumentiert
sie das gleich in den ersten
generationen also in den unmittelbaren
nachfolgen die er dir bei den unter den
ersten kalifen nach mohamed die lage von
frauen ist viel schlechter geworden weil
mehr oder weniger die führende männer
sehr frauenfeindlich waren und
frauenfeindliche aus mohammed und oder
bzw
frauenfeindlicher heißt die offenbarung
meinte dass ein frauenfeindlicher als
gott also gott ist nach ihrer lesung
feministisch aber die für muslimische
männer waren anti feministische und
deswegen sagt sie dass insgesamt das
ergebnis der des landes war sehr schnell
schlechter für frauen als vorher
also hier ist ein zitat wer sich aus dem
händler habe
reading the lord of the dance ist man
[Musik]
also die selbst determination von frauen
wurde abgelehnt aber nicht wegen der
offenbar das ist glaube ich eine eine
verkehrte auslegung des islams die schon
von den gleichen generationen entstanden
ist und sie bietet mehrere beispiele ein
sehr interessantes beispiel was sie sehr
lang bespricht in einen hunger ist es
gibt ein handys mohammed angeblich sagt
gesagt hat der der sein geschäft einer
frau hierfür gibt es wird nie davon
profitieren dass keine gute besetzung
habe denn wenn eine frau irgendwie
einmischt dann wirst du nicht
erfolgreich sein und für das mehr oder
weniger der punkt und das ist das wird
als starker aktiv in den usa hat die zu
handlungen beschrieben
und dann sagt sie oh okay jetzt gehen
wir in dieser kette und schauen wie das
vieh geliefert würde und dann geht sie
zurück zu den ersten glied in der kette
und sagt okay das ist dass es irgendein
mann und was wissen wir über ihn
wir wissen dass er in einem juristischen
prozess als lügner beurteilt würde also
diese angeblich starke kette ist
eigentlich sehr sehr schwach und würden
werde nie als stark erklärt wenn all
diese juristen diese sammler nicht
frauenfeindlich warten werden weil sie
wollten frauen schlecht machen und
deswegen wollten sie diese hat ist stark
haben aber die ist eigentlich sehr
schwach es interessant wenn man sieht
dass sie sozusagen die spielregeln
übernimmt also diese hat die kette und
so weiter sie spielt mit und sagt sagst
du dieses dass sie das besser machen
kann als die historische hadid gelernt
anderes beispiel ist jede auslegung eine
sehr berühmten passage aus dem koran die
immer erwähnt wird als basis für hitz ab
also für schleier tragen des schleiers
der schleier in des schleiers von frauen
und sie sagt okay jetzt lesen wir dass
vorsichtig und sehen was wirklich
dahinter steckt und sie erklärt dass im
kontext dass das ist eine beschreibung
einer hochzeitsnacht mohammed gerade
eine neue frau erworben hat und er will
mit ihr im privat sein und deswegen soll
ein hitler und das heißt vorhang ein
vorhang soll über gezogen werden um sie
zu decken von der gemeinde also von den
anderen gästen die da sind und das heißt
dass das überhaupt nichts mit schleier
zu tun hatte sein vorhaben also sieht
sie bietet diese haus natürlich kann man
darüber streiten aber ihre auslegung ist
dass das die ganze idee dass man dass
frauen einen job
zeugen sollen geht alles zurück auf eine
falsche auslegung des korans und das ist
was sie immer macht ok also wirklich
interessant weil wie gesagt dass sie
bleibt innerhalb den regeln der
klassischen islamischen auslegung
erkennt die autorität des korans und und
auch von der hertie faber argumentiert
dass setzt in den ersten generationen
der muslime dass diese kann immer falsch
ausgelegt würden also wirklich
interessant wirklich im allgemeinen aber
dementiert sie dass die generationen von
männern die das man theologen
juristen wie das gemacht haben einen
guten grund hat hatte das zu machen
nämlich dass das ist wirklich schön
sie hatten sagte sagt pan in der
westlichen welt hat man immer gedacht
dass frauen was frauen wirklich schwach
sind wir müssen von männern geschützt
werden
und deswegen hat man all diese ideen
dass sie zum beispiel männliche schütze
haben muss im gesetz und so weiter aber
im islam argumentiert sie das war genau
umgekehrt sie fürchteten dass männer
schwächer sind als frauen zum beispiel
männer können ihre sexuelle lust hier
nichts kontrollieren frauen schon und
die ihre erklärung warum diese hat diese
art werse falsch ausgelegt würde ist
dass männer fürchteten dass sie sich
nicht alles beherrschen könnten wenn sie
frauen sehen also kurzum es gibt nicht
die nicht um die frauen das ist ein
versuch die männer von sich selbst zu
schützen weil sie so schwach sind dass
sie nicht in der lage sind sich selbst
zu kontrollieren
in der anwesenheit der frauen es ist
natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen
ironisch gemeint oder als beleidigung
also praktisch sagt ist also wenn du als
muslimische waren denkt dass frauen
hinter up tragen soll
was sagt das über dich oder über deine
selbstdefinition du sagst praktisch über
sich selbst dass du nicht in der lage
bist frauen vorbei sehen sie können ohne
mit denen sex haben zu wollen
also das mag ich wirklich sehr gut
das finde ich wirklich schön und übrigen
ist an hier haben wir haben wir
vielleicht können sie sagen endlich eine
verbindung mit der philosophischen
koalition weil sie sie verbindet das mit
der platonischen theorie der seele wo
die untere seele
also viele lust hat und die vernunft das
regieren soll wie wir bei platon gesehen
haben und dann sagt sie anscheinend war
die ganze islamische juristische
situation der meinung dass frauen in der
lage sind die lustigen mit der von uns
zu konzentrieren aber männer nicht weil
es sonst würden die männer 20 minuten
die männer hätten absagen müssen
ja könnte man sagen okay ich hab das
sind ein paar beispiele was man über
islam und frauen sagen kann und von dem
was ich gesagt habe können sie jetzt
vielleicht die hoffnung haben also
frauen waren mitgeteilt in sehr wichtig
in sachen wie zum beispiel hat
überlieferung sicherlich in den letzten
100 jahren mehr oder weniger seit islam
gekommen ist gibt es viele weibliche
philosophen nennen die ich besprechen
könnte und dies wie gesagt leider ist
das nicht der fall
allerdings wenn ich zeigt wenn ich sage
die lage war so viel besser in den
westlichen oder verteilt wissen tun dass
das ist vielleicht erfüllen indem viele
von den vergorenen die ich oder in den
philosophen die ich in den kommenden
wochen besprechen werde
die galten hat die gelten als mystiker
allein das wort mystikerin hatte ich so
aufgeregt
also hände kalt oder hd wird schon so
weit dass also ich werde sie also sagen
alles für eines offenen behandeln aber
viele würden sagen die sind eigentlich
mystikerinnen und es gibt sie kennen in
also weibliche mystiker in islam also
weiblich sowie ist und deswegen wollte
ich ein paar erwähnen oder wird eine
eine erwähnen
sozusagen als gegenstück für leute wie
hält man könnte sich fragen warum nicht
eine ganze vorlesungen darüber und die
antwort ist die texte sind ein bisschen
zu zugang meiner meinung nach aber hätte
ich vielleicht machen können weil es
gibt mehrere weibliche denn die
wichtigste auf jeden fall ist rabia
khodr ramadan dass sie lebt genau wissen
wir nicht aber das letzte irgendwann im
achten jahrhundert nach christus also
das heißt tiefe islam kommt im siebten
jahrhundert philosophie fängt eigentlich
im neunten jahrhundert also deutlich
früher und sie ist eine sehr sehr
wichtige person in der geschichte des
sufismus weil sie unter deck weise den
ersten mystikerin müsste können
überhaupt zählt und vor allem weil sie
ein thema eingeführt hat was sehr
berühmtesten sehr bekannt in der
geschichte des sufismus und dass es
liebe für gott sogar erotische liebe für
gott
sie hat an sie ist eigentlich bekannt
durch weise so spät schon
nämlich hinter der vision beschleunigen
müssen sie hat sie ist eine durch
gedichten bekannt und diesen gedichten
sagt beschreibt sie ihre liebe für gott
und wenn man zum beispiel einen dichter
wie romy denkt lumi übernimmt dieses
thema von rabia unter anderen auto also
nur als beispiel habe ich eine zitat
ausgewählt liebe zu gott findet mich
daran geschaffene dinge zu leben das ist
sehr typisch viele ist so viele
weibliche sophies übrigens war
einheiratet also nicht wie ich
beschrieben habe in der spätantike wo
frauen praktisch aus der familie
ausgestiegen sind und an geworden sind
die meiste weibliche sophies waren in
einer familie
manchmal war das ein bisschen skandalös
weil sie so hemmungslos geschrieben
haben oder sich benommen haben aber es
ist noch eine stärkere ausnahme sie hat
sich nichts sie hatten die verheiratet
und war praktisch frei stehende
mystikerin und von daher könnte man
sagen dass sie sie schildert die
situation eine nonne die helligkeit ein
bisschen aber ohne institutionelle
kontext so viel zu fragen des islam
fragen dazu kurz vor ich dann weitergehe
nur kurz zu besuch
soweit ich weiß gibt es keine eigentlich
keine philosophische werke von frauen
die erhalten sind aus besonders das
beste was ich kenne und ich würde es ja
gehört gerne hören wenn jemand weiß was
besser das kennt aber das beste was ich
kenne es ankommt
sie haben vielleicht von ihr gehört also
wenn sie was über die szenische
geschichte haben sie sicherlich von ihr
gehört sie hat ein ein hauptwerk der
persönlichen geschichte geschrieben also
geschichte jemand das buch ist über
geschichte das ist eine beschreibung das
leben ihres vaters der kaiser alexius
com - und ist nach dem genanntes alexia
auf englisch alexy hat weil sie gehabt
deutsch wahrscheinlich auf deutsch
alexia sie ist 1000 338 1083 geboren und
1147 gestorben
also ist mittelalterlich und haben sie
beschreibt viele wichtige ist solche
ereignisse im leben her des vaters aber
was und das selbst interessant dass wir
nicht ein riesiges werk von einer frau
haben was sehr oft gelesen wird von
leute die diesen tierische geschichte
stehen
aber was bei ihr noch interessanter ist
ist dass sie also im hof hatte sie ist
über prinzessin also natürlich hat sie
einen kreis in ihrem hof und in diesem
kreis waren mehrere philosophen
vorhanden
zum beispiel michael von offices der
kommentar des ortes geschrieben und sie
kennt und lobt in dem alex ii askemper
der andere philosophen unter anderen
zwei haupt bekannten philosophen aus dem
zwölften jahrhundert war johannes etat
los und ist ratlos das ist praktisch wie
wahrscheinlich sind die namen hin nicht
bekannt aber das sind gehören zu den
zehn wichtigsten philosophen haus der in
der business edition geschichte und sie
waren praktisch angestellt als freunde
oder berater oder lehrer von dieser
prinzessin eine kommune die selbst ein
buch geschrieben hat
leider ist das buch vom inhalt her
eigentlich nichts zu philosophisch aber
immerhin haben wir hier eine beziehung
zwischen einer mächtigen frau und
philosophie und die man man sieht aus
dem buch das sie ist auch philosophisch
gebildet war vor allem haben michael von
ephesos war entscheiden hier lehrer in
philosophie was ja auch mathematik und
so weiter studiert hier könnte man eine
kommunale vielleicht mit julia donner
vergleichen und ich glaube sie habe sie
erwähnt irgendwann sie ist in 217
gestorben und war die frau von
septembers der römische kaiser und hätte
sie hat sich auch ein kreis von
mathematikern und philosophen angeblich
um sie versammelt also das ist ein
phänomen was ist schon erwähnt habe es
gibt ab und zu diese mächtige frauen
frauen frauen oder tochter von kaiser in
diesem fall und wenn es die
philosophische interessen hatten waren
sie in der lage philosophen um sich zu
sammeln und mit denen ideen aus den
taschen bleiben wenn jetzt nicht viel
viele texte die uns davon berichten
können wichtige und für uns ist nicht
reicher ist die lateinische tradition
und
hier finden werden wir jetzt sehen
werden in den kommenden wochen gab es
schon die gelegenheit im gegensatz
anscheinend so besonders und der in der
islamischen welt gab es die gelegenheit
für frauen die eigene ideen zu
entwickeln
auch ohne dass sie in der kaiserlichen
familie waren man könnte also gegen mein
beispiel von einer kommune hätte man
vielleicht sagen das zelt nichts sie ist
die tochter eines kaisers also wenn es
ein ausnahmefall gibt dann das aber
immer eine hildegard von bingen ist
keine superreiche keine superreich
immerhin ihre familie war wohlhabend
aber sie ist nichts eine prinzessin sich
nicht eine kaiserin oder die mutter eine
eines gunsten oder so was sie es nur
eine gebildete frau die erhaltenen werke
geschrieben hat das ist was anderes
und man könnte sich fragen warum warum
gibt es diese möglichkeit in latein
christentum und nicht in diesen anderen
gesellschaften und meine antwort
kurzum das werden wird detaillierter
sehen aber kurzum es meine antwort
institutionen hier institutionen sind
sehr wichtig service für die geschichte
hilflos wie und besonders in diesem fall
erstens erklärt das warum wir hildegard
ins würfen jahrhundert haben können denn
philosophie bis ende des zwölften
jahrhunderts immer in monastischen
situationen stattgefunden hat oder
innerhalb einer familie vielleicht aber
vorwiegend in japan unter münchen und
manche oder oder in münchen und am ring
oder haben anhin schulen die an einer
kirche verbunden waren
und das hieß dass genau wie zb an sein
muss alsmanns philosophische werke für
seine schule scheinen könnte genau so
konnte hildegard werke für jede in einem
schreiben oder brief ja zum beispiel
scheinen das wird sehr anders nach der
nachdem die universitäten kommen dass
sie sind ein späten zwölften jahrhundert
und die universitäten beherrschen dann
sozusagen die hauptströmung der
philosophie total im dreizehnte
vierzehnte und sogar fünfzehnten
jahrhundert also mit einer chance kommt
etwas anderes wo wir sozusagen gegen
drastische philosophen haben die
außerhalb des systems sind aber in 2 10
14 jahrhundert alles was wir
normalerweise als philosophie mit artig
für das betrachten
das findet in eine universitätsstadt und
universitäten haben keine frauen
es gibt keine universität ische frauen
in 13 oder 14 jahre und das was sie
machen also studentinnen zu sein
die weiblichen studenten die hier sind
dass man damals nicht möglich
das ist sehr wichtig als beobachtung
weil das bestimmt die möglichkeiten für
frauen in dieser zeit philosophie zu
treiben
und jetzt könnte man vielleicht denken
okay wie kann das eine erklärung sein
warum wir doch frauen haben
antwort die die erwartung dass für das
vieh nur innerhalb einer universität
passieren kann ist selbst falsch es gibt
philosophische werke
durch das 13 und 14 jahrhundert die
nichts an einer universität geschrieben
werden
und die waren oft mit was ich vorher
gesagt habe volkssprache verbunden
beispiel nannte dante hat dante war
nichts universitäts meister war nicht
wie thomas von der queen oder ballade
oder albertus magnus
er war dichter und schriftsteller und
intellektueller hat aber werke wie wir
philosophie geschrieben zum beispiel
thema nach rheinberg gebe über
politisches wie zwar auf lateinisch aber
mein punkt ist dass dieser volkssprache
freundlich schriftsteller dante hat auch
über philosophie geschieden oder ein
drittes beispiel beispiel deutsche
mystic viele werke der deutschen mystik
würden von nichts universitären
gelehrten geschieden und oft auf deutsch
also man könnte sagen dass frauen mit
natürlichem philosophinnen sind oft teil
einer sozusagen eine bewegung innerhalb
der mitlaufenden philosophie die im
allgemeinen oft unterbewertet wird weil
man immer wenn man ein mittel für das
vieh denkt denkt man immer ans
klassizismus
da denkt man an thomas von aquin
scooters vielleicht könne dann noch im
14 jahrhundert man denken nicht an dante
oder zum beispiel nannte men der autor
der romande de roos hatte eine
ausbildung an der uni aber als dichter
war er unabhängig von der von der
universitäts und hat einfach dieses werk
geschrieben in volkssprache wo er sich
zu viele philosophische themen und ideen
äußert das war alles möglich
problem ist nur dass
philosophiehistoriker das passt immer
aus der sicht lassen also die die denken
nichts an johnson oder dante wenn sie
ein mittler wie philosophie denken
die denken dann thomas von aquin und das
ist für uns wichtig weil die die frauen
die wir jetzt besprechen werden können
die sind die haben oft viel mehr
ähnlichkeit zu einem dante oder johnson
als zu thomas von aquin selbst innerhalb
der universität
da haben sie mehr gemeinsam zum beispiel
mit bonaventura also ein argentinischer
denke der ein derartiges ein bisschen
fern halten wollte
die haben mehr mit ihnen gemeinsam als
zum beispiel mit thomas also man könnte
sagen das ist ein punkt den ich schon
mehrmals gemacht habe das werde ich
wieder machen
wenn man die bereitschaft frauen kennst
zu nehmen in der geschichte philosophie
kommt oft zusammen mit einer
bereitschaft im allgemein offener zu
sein gegenüber was philosophie ist oder
sein könnte und auffälligste ist
natürlich mystizismus also wenn man wenn
man behauptet mystical sind keine
philosophen ich bin nicht bereit ein
mystiker als vieles zu nehmen
dann werde ich meister eckhart
ausschließen und bonaventura und auch
hildegard von julian von deutsch und so
weiter wenn aber das ist nicht nur und
man führt deswegen denkt also man könnte
die liste von frauen auf dem
vorlesungsplan anscheinend denken ja das
geht hier nur mystizismus aber erstens
das ist nicht der fall wie versehen
werden aber es geht nicht nur mist
mystik es gibt gegen scu rassismus und
andere arten von philosophie im
mittelalter es geht um lateinische werke
und volkssprache werke
es geht um das monarchische kultur &
scholars tische universitäts kultur die
frauen sind sozusagen immer im rahmen
den nach verlässlichsten die in der nach
verletzung hälfte vorhanden
ich würde vielleicht so laut sagen dass
in zwei aspekte hier die sich
gegenseitig unterstützen nämlich ein
tendenz frauen sowieso nie ernst zu
nehmen in der geschichte ist wie und
auch die die arten von text die frauen
geschrieben haben auch wenn sie von
männern geschrieben wenn auch nicht
ernst zu nehmen
im allgemeinen ist sozusagen noch einmal
wo wir sagen könnte dass das versuch
frauen als philosophinnen herz zu nehmen
und verständnis der philosophie in einer
bestimmten zeit verbreiten kann und das
werden wir so ein paar gleich am anfang
sehen nächste woche weil also nächste
woche geht es um hildegard von bingen
aber bevor ich sie besprechen werde ich
auch kurz was zu eloise sagen und das
ist
ich will das und das hat dann war sie
auch im zwölften jahrhundert war wie via
handy
aber was ich damit sagen will ist dass
wir ein bisschen jetzt ein kurzes
beispiel warum wir ein bisschen offen
sein müssen wenn wir denken was für das
ist wie mit leute ist weil jeder wie
jede geschichte der philosophie im
mittelalter hat was über aber dazu sagen
aber wenige geschichten über der flosse
wie im mittelalter haben was über seine
liebhaberin office liebhaber ein
helleres zu sagen obwohl sie ein
austausch haben wo sie gegenseitig
briefe geschrieben haben
und obwohl helau ist eine logische
argumente anbietet wie sie beide ihre
beziehung sein sollen
und es gibt wie sie das an werden
relativ viel darüber zu sagen aber ich
werde versuchen das nur in einer halben
stunde abzudecken oder weniger und dann
werde ich die restliche zeit nächste
woche über hildegard von bingen zwar
okay glaube die zeit ist jetzt um aber
hat jemand fragen als zwei minuten
befragen
über frauen im islam oder die chance
dass auch immer
klappt philosophie war eigentlich immer
hast genau das gesehen also vielleicht
hätten vieles offen gesagt wenn alle für
diesen tieren macht das wie machen
würden müssten fahren keine schleier zu
halten oder vielleicht durch presse
religion würde würde die meinerseits
beherrschung erwerben
natürlich ist da immer ein natürlich ist
nicht eine weit verbreitete these dass
frauen passt sich stroman sich in der
sonne oder sowas weil männer schwachsinn
das ist mehr eine auslegung die man es
macht und wie gesagt das ist vielleicht
die männer ein bisschen zu fixen
ja also ich glaube sie würde sagen das
ist das ist in islamischer kultur von
anfang an geprägt weil die erste
generation frauenfeindlich waren und sie
dann soviel einfluss hatten auf die
auslegung der persönlichen gefallen zb
dass sie diese falsche hat dies als
stark erklärt haben alle happy
vielen dank das nächste woche